this is a production of Cornell
University
usually when you give a talk you know
you or you try to connect yourself to
the place you know like oh the last time
I was here was 15 years ago when I was
skiing and whatever it it's like the
last time I was here was when I came in
this morning and went up the elevator
but anyway it's really nice to be
talking to a familiar group of faces and
this is some work that's been ongoing
for several years a little bit of it
will be familiar to those of you who saw
my talk when I interviewed here in 2012
and that was a an eventful time in the
boulder colorado i was there for the
summer 2012 and this is the picture I
took when we were evacuated from the
Mesa lab which doesn't show up well but
it's right here and June during the big
wildfires this is the same month when a
lot of Colorado Springs was devastated
by wild ours we actually saw the
lightning strike that started this one I
was on the top floor of the Mesa lab I
had office mates who had westward facing
windows and doors they opened up the
doors to go out and look at the big
smoke because it was starting to
accumulate and then the wind started to
change and then it started to blow smoke
into the offices and then the
loudspeaker came on you know the
announcement that we needed to evacuate
the building I took this picture on the
way down from my bike on my iPhone later
that summer many people know be familiar
with the drought their wedding in Iowa
they were calling it the great corn
apocalypse of 2012 and this is a picture
of what some of the effects look like
after all this end of the end of the
summer getting back after being
evacuated in the lab my advisor at the
time Clara guesser so climate scientist
works at Mesa lab asked me if she knew I
was working on mega droughts prolonged
Ron she asked if this is what we were
experiencing 2012 was a mega droughts
and of course want to give a really good
answer so I was like yes no maybe and I
should have said what I should have said
but I realize now what I should have
said then was asked me in 35 years
because mega droughts the definition is
really
dependent on this time scale of a
prolonged period of aridity and the
question remains people still will still
want to know are we in a mega droughts
in particular when your position is
extreme weather during climate change at
Cornell University people ask you is it
a mega droughts I have a good answer
wait 32 years get back to you so this is
current conditions this is probably
going to weaken a little bit this little
a bait a little bit with the big giant
rainfall events that are happening right
now in the southeast the West is very
dry anomalously dry as you can see and
the definition using the Wikipedia
definition because I hey think I know
who wrote it and it captures a lot of
what the scientific literature up till
recently has been saying about this term
mega droughts I'll let you read it
yourself I learned something interesting
about the world of the internet when I
gave a talk at age you a number of years
ago about mega droughts and I read my
definition out loud so therefore you can
quote professor saying that they
constitute a threat to civilization your
USA today so graduate students in
particular be careful what you say
historically that's an accurate
statement prolonged periods of aridity
in the past and past molino ver the past
millennia are to have being linked to
the demise of some very famous pre
industrial empires now does that mean
there are a threat to civilization today
very different question we just go over
some other events that are noteworthy
because they have been either correctly
or not they've been labeled or
attributed to being of mega droughts
there's a dust bowl which is about a
decade six years a really bad drought
decade total if you look at the average
on this we've got the Palmer drought
severity excess index on the y-axis
plotted downward
and the duration here and then the size
of the dots that I'm going to show is
the spatial extent so these are all but
these have all been events that have in
some published literature in terms of
mega droughts or at least prolonged rub
Australia's big dry a little bit smaller
live less severe but still very
consequential
amazon drought of 2005 and also you
could add 2011 to this it was similar in
scale I think and it was not very
long-lived selves annual but had a
strong impact on fire and carbon in the
area as I understand dry down a lot of
the for us and if they're related to a I
think a prolonged dry season just a very
badly timed wave in the atmosphere that
pushed out the moisture for an extra few
weeks leading to the job but a
short-lived very short-lived and big and
then the the big big granddaddy of them
all is of course the Sahel job which was
very consequential for parts of Africa
and the effects are probably still think
felt in the region today so there's this
distinction maybe that had been made
still gets made in while the
high-profile papers on this between what
we would kind of probably called route
versus mega droughts on the drought side
you might have things like you know the
2012 event short-lived and but then when
it starts to get out to being really
impactful headline-grabbing it's very
very attractive to start calling it a
mega droughts it's a very compelling
term to use a drought that is having a
very strong visible impact and so there
wasn't i mean the line is very blurry
and the line is blurry because primarily
the the term is a compelling worth to
use when you're trying to get grants
funded and papers published we tried to
be a little more quantitative we looked
you know we actually started looking at
this even multi millennial scale periods
of dryness in the southwest other parts
of the world happening on you know
during the Ice Ages right you've got
thousands of years where climate just
dries up those multi-thousand your
events were being called mega droughts
in some of the papers so you've got what
six orders of magnitude in time being
covered by this blanket term mega
droughts when I talk about mega droughts
and this talk and in the stuff that
we've been doing when I'm talking about
Maggie drought I'm really thinking about
multi-decade oh yeah multiple decades
meaning shorter like one decade try to
call decade old route
and a lot longer than a few decades and
we have to start thinking about whether
or not it's driven by climate change
either natural or unforced but climate
change not necessarily a interval that
is dry for a period of decades and then
returns to being normal and because
we're talking about events that unfold
that evolved over multiple decades
they're really at the edge of all the
different types of observational or
apparatuses methods of inference that we
have so we don't have historical records
going back thousands of years and we
certainly don't have satellites going
back for more than just a few decades so
what I this is a schematic diagram that
I put together and you can see the time
scale here and think of this is like the
quality of the date or the resolution
the data the precision it's what i'm
calling it here so for satellites you've
got a lot of detailed information but
only for a few decades instrumental data
the detail is not a space that the data
is not a spatially complete but it's
still pretty good but you can't quite go
down maybe in all cases everywhere
globally to the same high frequency end
of the end of the timescales can't go
down two days in most cases with
observational data globally and then
there you got drought you've got weather
as events that happen we move out to
study mega droughts some of the best
evidence and I'm going to talk about
this today comes from paleoclimate
archives for the fact that happened in
the past and then in the very top here
the the global climate models you could
say our legitimate on these time skills
they're being run with boundary
conditions designed to simulate the
natural variability in the climate
system over the last millennium and
they're certainly able to generate data
on timescales of days all the way out to
millennia and there's no problem with
measuring the variables that are
simulated by a climate model that
directly simulated but they are at best
approximations of reality macaulay who
likes to call them earth-like planets
these global climate models or
earth-like planets I have many am glad I
made thank you three people
and then we've got climate change all
the way out here the top which is
unfolding over centuries mega droughts
is really right here where you can try
and use the different types of methods
of inference that different data
products available that are legitimate
on these heimer aizen's to say something
about the characteristics of these
events in the past so you've got proxies
halo climate archives like tree rings
instrumental data and gc-ms and wanted
to show some pictures of decayed old
route most sailing example of course the
Dust Bowl in the US this is April 14th
black sunday believe right like sunday
april 14th and see this wall of dust
moving in its catastrophic people who
read the book the worst hard times we
see in the PBS documentary ken burns be
familiar with the idea that the dust was
killing people infants and and elderly
people in particular we're very
seriously affected by the dust it caused
the type of pneumonia called dust
pneumonia just from the inhalation it's
really really damaging I need to tell
you guys this this is when I talking to
climate scientists to sell this all
right 1950s this picture from 1950s
throughout lesser-known maybe not as
visible sailing example but certainly
very painful for agriculture for farmers
and growers who lived in the south west
during that time in fact after some of
these studies came out I got an email
from a Cornell alum saying that you know
his family has been growing crops in
Texas remember the 1950s being really
really bad multi year intervals of
aridity that we're really really bad and
that's all in my bin my notion of
drought the bin of decay ttle drought
you go ten years in either direction
from these events you're not really
seeing the same effects as during that
decade of drug it also lends itself to a
pretty convenient method for detecting
de que de land multidecadal droughts
because if you just look at the
precipitation anomalies alone pick your
favorite index favorite drought index
and there's lots of them and they lead
you to a similar story but just take
precipitation alone right here we've got
in grey precipitation totals Great
Plains its annual averages and black is
a smoothing curve like a 10 year moving
average and then here we've got one half
of one standard deviation and you can
see that the black curve stays below one
half of one standard deviation for the
entire period of the job it's a
objective metric that lets us pull out
these things from data apply the same
thing and you can see the same type of
threshold applies to the southwest job
to nineteen fifties so just as a
starting point for a definition of a
drought that we know would be bad be as
much of a precipitation deficit that we
saw during the 1950s in 1930s this works
half a standard deviation is a long-term
average the 10-year average seems to
seems to identify these intervals and
not spurious lee identify other
intervals which is good we got
precipitation we've got moisture we've
got tree ring measurements we can try to
apply this to a picture of Connie
Woodhouse right there up on a
mountainside and they think it's the San
Joaquin mountains in southern Colorado
coring a tree I got to go out with the
tree-ring folks once only once when I
was at the University of Arizona doing
my graduate work and i think i was able
to core about three trees in the time
that one of the superstar Dedrick
climatologist court like 24 and I was
super sore the next day you go the
Swedish coring device that crankin and
it's exhausting work I mean maybe some
of you do it I I always thought I was
really like in good shape do I gotta go
to the gym I go out there and core trees
with these Dendra climatologist know
there's dipping up and down he's like 45
degrees love mountains on screen and
drilling out chords of trees at a rate
that is impressive it's very impressive
at the time when I was in graduate
school of universe Arizona the world
famous tree ring lab
Denver climatology was right underneath
here then the stadium of Arizona of
arizona football stadium and i was i was
persuaded upon by a good friend
colleague Scott st. George and have an
itch keitus Botha who had finished a few
years before me to go and see if I could
convince Dave Miko's world-famous
dandruff climatologist someone in the
room I know has worked on with various
papers and proposals convince him if I
could do a study abroad in his office
across campus in the in the Denver
climatology lab there's very convenient
on a Saturday if you're working on a
saturday you know you want some nachos
you just go just go right across the
hall get your nachos from the concession
stand and then go back to work and of
course this is like rich woody smell in
all the labs and all the offices and the
guys they work their have these big
beards they've been doing it forever and
you feel like you're in Lord of the
Rings you feel like you're just
surrounded by answers are or some
mythical creatures that go out into the
forest with superpowers and bring back
climate archives and so one of the
things that I learned about when I was
there I was very interested in this idea
of how well can we make inferences from
peering data about low-frequency
variability in Hydra climate and how
might that inform our understanding of
drought statistics particularly mega
droughts statistics on these
multidecadal even multiply millennial
time horizons so you go into the tree
onto the field in the summer and make a
bunch of drill bunch of course which
look about like this bring it back to
lab measure the ring widths and then
they usually just get plotted up to
begin with as ring width measurement
industry's not even indices I just ring
with measurements this is just raw ring
width from what one two three four five
six different trees nothing has been
done to massage the data it's just what
you get when you get back to the lab and
you spend your time measuring up there's
also a very important step that gets
overlooked and has been overlooked in
some very high-profile high-impact
papers it's important to understand and
it's how these things are aligned in
time it's a very quantitative very
precise science its sequences of
relatively wide in there
rings are very good indicators of of a
time period they're like a barcode their
unique and they can be used to match
where things must align in time and they
have been and they're also very
effective for identifying places where
growth is missing during a year we happy
to talk about that after the talk but
the main point here is that in this case
mostly is actually ended when the tree
was sampled and then you can just count
time going backwards on the x-axis here
raw ring with measurements typically one
then tries to model the non climate
influences on tree ring growth this is
important going through and a lot of
detail because it's really important to
our understanding of mega droughts
fundamentally overall in this case i did
a spline just a smoothing curve to the
ring with indices to try to estimate the
non climate sources of growth typically
splines are set to be you know removing
one hundred percent of the variants at
two-thirds the length of the segment
other more stiff splines might be
something like a negative exponential
that models growth as being very sharp
in the beginning and then decaying
rapidly other ones still are more
flexible the latest and greatest best
methods best practices for de trending
try to estimate the growth from each
individual site as a residual once you
factor in the total field of growth
across sites that makes sense there's
lots of different methods and it's
really important on the long timescales
to get it right or at least to be able
to quantify and understand what you're
missing or what you might be missing and
what you're removing because typically
you're chopping out the low frequency
end of the spectrum you're chopping out
the low frequency variability if for no
other reason then the simplest possible
case a tree is putting on the same
amount of carbon each year but because
its radius is getting bigger the width
of the ring has to get smaller there's
more going on in real trees right
there's biological processes they shift
away from using resources to grow
towards using resources for reproduction
so there's all kinds of non-climate
sources of variability on these
multidecadal
century time skills that need to be
accounted for or factored in or
investigate it if we want to get it at
this problem of mega drove once those
once that's been done usually do a de
trending using those smiles imagine
subtracting that there's a second step
that's often applied to standardize them
to unit variance and that's we've got
here so these are ring with indices now
not measurements anymore they've been
detrended and standardized to be ring
with indices and this is just a subset
from one site I think in the San Joaquin
mountains as well usually there'll be a
few dozen trees going into a compilation
of ring with indices make a compilation
of ring with indices you've got tree
ring chronology and that's what I've
done here just illustrative purposes the
chronology it's like a weighted average
or an average of the individual
constituent ring with indices via the
central limit theorem and it's important
to factor in in our understanding of
Hydra climate and trees that these sites
have been pre-selected to be moisture
sensitive you're in the southwest they
go out to parts of the mountains where
it's very likely that moisture is the
limiting factor on growth you go to a
high up it's probably temperature you go
to low while you're in cactus in the
southwest in this middle zone you got
long live trees and moisture is the
primary limiting factor on growth which
gives you a good chance at being able to
reconstruct moisture variables like the
Palmer drought severity index like
precipitation like Colorado streamflow
and those reconstructions now are
derived from sets of chronology so
dozens of ring with measurements go into
making ring with indices ring with
indices are then averaged together to
make chronologies chronologies then are
used to do a single reconstruction again
via the central limit theorem we hope
this all works out but it might not work
out the same way on different time
scales and that's something that's
active area of research in the case of
the Colorado River this is from Miko at
all 2007 the same Dave Miko I shared an
office with a little while
the reconstructed flow as a percentage
of the 20th century mean so one hundred
percent the 20th century mean very
famous figure this is probably one of
the most widely used paleo climate
results out there serve flow in black is
the 25 year running mean that's a thick
black line the thin black line is the
smoothing same smoothing 25 year running
me of the reconstruction the gray
shading is the over the confidence
limits and what you can see is this
event back in the 11 50s among others
drops below eighty seven percent of the
20th century mean for at least one year
and actually in the case of 11 50s it's
about 11 years this is not a great
definition of mega drove it's very hard
to communicate that we're talking about
the an interval that's characterized by
an 11-year drop in the 25 year running
mean at eighty-seven percent below of
20th century averages so he tried that
to that definition for a while we had a
bunch of papers rejected with that
definition the guide to simplify it
which is why I've introduced the other
one that we can actually use for this
analysis there's one event that
satisfies those criteria a 11 year 11
years below eighty seven percent of the
20th century mean and the 25 year
running average there's one event and
it's the 11 50s mega droughts that's
been incorporating a lot of decision
making about how to use water resources
in the Colorado if you just look at the
point when Flo gets that st. st.
eighty-seven percent threshold there are
a few other intervals and these have all
been called mega droughts I would call
them to kadel trout maybe that 11-50 s
drive qualifies the megadrop multiple
years 25 year running in if and we can
then look at other hydra climate
reconstructions from the same region up
here just pull down all those places
that I circle before to show you these
two kadel droughts and they're happening
in about a rate of one to two times per
century look
med benchmark and if you look at some of
these other reconstructions this is the
Palmer drought severity index also
reconstructed from trees also for the
southwest they're not completely in sync
even though it's a similar region is
interesting in and of itself but you do
get a similar rate one to two of these
de kado droughts per century this is
from Staley at all 2011 also a PDS I
reconstruction from northern Mexico now
and it's important again to notice that
it's not like these events are lining up
in time so there is maybe an inherent
spatial scale there's information there
that we can use to try and understand
the nature of these four long droughts
all right and then if we go back we
further apply a more rigorous smoothing
look for intervals that are below this
negative five standard deviation
negative negative point five standard
deviation the running mean the 35-year
running mean there's really only three
did not as the North American drought
atlas and this gives us an answer to a
question that a lot of people been
asking for a long time and the first
paper to address this was in 1998 by
Jonathan overpeck it's one of my
advisors in Arizona and their answer
back in 1998 to this question of how
likely are mega droughts from
paleoclimate perspective was that de
kado droughts looked like they were
occurring of what once or twice per
century perfectly consistent with our
idea of the 1930s Dust Bowl as well as
the 1950s drought in the southwest the
cable droughts occurring once or twice
per century and these multidecadal mega
droughts now multidecadal mega Joe
35-year interval thirty five year period
of aridity maybe one or two per
millennium very rare events and these
statistics seem pretty much to hold up
there's initial estimates from the
candiate held up pretty well with our
more quantitative analysis of more data
ended up in the same ballpark
now to get it the likelihood of mega
droughts we want to know something about
the past from paler climate perspective
from tree ring with measurements turn
with indices we also want to know
something about the underlying
statistical characteristics of Hydra
climate in the region and a really
convenient tool especially for comparing
with models is the power spectrum and
specifically the the color quote-unquote
of the power spectrum so if we've got
time scale here on the x-axis and
amplitude some Hydra climate variable
psi streamflow a red spectrum is going
to have generally more variants time
scales white would be like a uniform
distribution of variance across time
scales and blue so you don't see in very
many natural systems but you do in some
of these earth-like GCMs a great example
of this is the community climate system
model three so a couple generations ago
it would give you an El Nino La Nina
cycle every other year so be El Nino La
Nina el nino it's like a ping-pong ball
being batted back and forth from one
side of the table the other well if
you're sampling that at an annual
resolution you're going to get this big
peak right at the Nyquist frequency and
that would be like a blue power spectrum
where the variance is pushed away from
the long time scales and concentrated
the shortest ones so in nature there I
guess relatively rare I thinks I think
the people who do seismic imaging have
to worry about that kind of a spectrum
but they're relatively rare in nature
this was a paper result from a favor
from fibers and curry in 2006 very
important very significant paleoclimate
result where they look at the power
spectra of temperature so not Hydra
climate per se but temperature across
you know several orders of magnitude so
from seasonal all the way out to
millennium multi millennia so we're
talking from Milankovitch down to
seasonal time scale and they argue that
there's this just general redness
steepness to the spectral slope that's
positive for temperature up to century
long time scales here there's some
inflection point and then you go down to
more of the sort of the
the nonlinear Brownian motion regime
which is really potentially very
interesting from a long time scale
climate dynamics perspective and may
have some implications for climate
change and I was really just interested
in adapting this whole framework to
Hydra climate to ask if we could come up
with a similar type of diagram from
Hydra climate proxies and compare them
with temperature to compare the power
spectrum of Hydra climate because
presumably if you have very red power
spectrum and power spectra that are red
on long time scales that would mean
something different about the risks of
mega droughts because you be able to
stay in a dry regime for a long time
because there's a high amplitude to
those low frequency timescales versus if
you have a white door blue power
spectrum and one thing though that makes
us a little more complicated for
moisture soil moisture and other
archives of Hydra climate as opposed to
temperature is storage so the harbor's
and curry paper is able to get away with
using very coarse resolution proxies
proxies that are geochemical the half
you know relatively small basins to
worry about with with mixing timescales
of maybe a few decades or even a few
hundred years or even if you're you know
if you're looking at the karaoke base
and you're worried about the whole ocean
you still are only worrying about a few
millennia and they're going out the
hundreds of millennia where is for mega
droughts for Cadle drought we do have to
think about what effects are we going to
have of the sensor the tree-ring
measurement itself on the distribution
of variance the power spectrum and this
is a simple idealized drawing where you
can imagine some white noise input being
filtered through the proxy tree ring
with being a function both of annual
moisture availability but also previous
year's growth in situ soil moisture a
host of other factors that are going to
smooth out those high frequency
fluctuations and emphasize the longer
time scales
and the simplest model that probably
come up with one can come up with to try
and quantify this effect it's this first
order autoregressive process so you've
just got your proxy at time T it's a lot
of correlation coefficient and noise and
we can investigate this using the Palmer
drought severity index which has a
prescribed autocorrelation coefficient
of 0.8 97 from one month to the next so
it's not point nine it is 0.8 97 from
one month to the next month and we can
use that to calculate an analytical
power spectrum and do monte carlo
simulations of pds I to get at you know
the range of amplitudes that one could
predict on these longer timescales
solely from autocorrelation and a white
noise background so if there's no other
show in town in the southwest besides
weather and autocorrelation this is the
power spectrum we predict analytically
in this black line and with Monte Carlo
realizations in the gray shading the
very nice benchmark then against which
we can compare a collection of Hydra
climate proxies the style of homers and
curry and Hydra climate proxies now in
the southwest so up here we've got in
the colored lines different tree-ring
reconstructions reconstructions all of
them all available reconstructions of
all stream flow variables in red all
precipitation reconstructions in purple
and then this is a really pristine or
really high-quality very carefully
constructed data set that Connie would
house and her conduct colleagues put
together from the five needle pines in
the southwest and it was designed to
have the best chance of preserving those
low frequency time skills by only using
long segments so at the stage where
you're building a chronology they threw
out anything that was shorter than like
two hundred years or 250 years so so
right off the bat you've got a good
chance of having long segments which are
required because of how the trick the d
trending is applied me long segments you
already got long segments
and then they also additionally apply
very conservative d trending so trying
to leave in as much of that low
frequency variability as possible while
still removing the non climate vectors
the other archives on here are non
tree-ring so the symbols are non
tree-ring proxies from lakes and caves
and then the grey line is their average
and there's some things that are a
little surprising and some things that
aren't very surprising this diagram to
me one is that for the most part the
tree-ring records on these Dickens's
about a decade century millennium most
of the tree-ring reconstructions other
than this five needle pine very pristine
data set are well within the confidence
limits the really significant result and
a really problematic one for lots of
reasons it means that for most of the
streamflow reconstructions that we have
the emergence of mega droughts of de
kado droughts at least is not outside of
what you would expect from stochastic
forcing plus a little autocorrelation
and a bunch of time right you're right
in the middle there but you have these
other proxies pointing at a different
story and we know that there's some de
trending applied to these when the
variance dropping down here is may be
indicative of that that the de trending
itself is removing variance in these
long time scales from these other
reconstructions whereas in the non
tree-ring reconstructions non-trading
proxies there's no de trending and
they're all giving you this kind of red
shape that's aligned fairly well with
the five needle pine database so the
weight of evidence from this diagram is
towards rejecting the null hypothesis in
other words it's not that the only show
in town is autocorrelation stochastic
forcing in a bunch of time there's
something more interesting happening on
these longer timescales driving the low
frequency variability reject the null
hypothesis
with more data we probably will have to
revisit this whole paradigm but for now
it doesn't seem like we have any reason
to think that the variance out here in
these proxies is driven by something
other than climate processes so the one
do this purely from Statistics now we've
got different noise models that we could
apply based on the autocorrelation or
low frequency behavior of the paler
climate archives we have try to
reproduce their variations through time
statistically and come up with an
assessment of prolonged drought mega
droughts likelihood and that's what we
did in one of these papers where we just
looked at white noise air one and then a
power-law distribution in frequency
power law distribution to try and get at
this long long time scale high amplitude
tail in the power spectrum what's really
cool I think about this figure is that
so we the way that we we constructed our
methods you can compare in time the
different types of noise models and on
short time horizons of 50 years it
almost makes no difference you're
getting the same kinds of stats and they
all the same exact variance 0 mean on
longer time scales we were only looking
at the interannual fluctuations you'd
still even if I wasn't using gray
shading here to save money journal of
climate publication charges but you're a
sizable even if I wasn't you'd still be
hard-pressed to tell the differences but
now when you smooth you look only for
the low frequency components the
power-law distribution has this
persistence that really pops out and so
you stay away from the mean both above
and below the mean for longer when
you're looking at the power law
distribution which is what you'd expect
but that could be important for trying
to characterize the risk of mega
droughts and indeed it matters quite a
bit so these are just different PDFs
different ways of looking at these Monte
Carlo simulations to characterize the
risk number of years spent in a dick
anal drought the cable drought risk as a
fraction of all 50 year periods
experiencing one of these events and
multi dko mega droughts risk it really
matters out here when you get onto the
multi
cadle mega droughts risk if the system
were fundamentally white in nature if it
was a white noise process generating
droughts you would have only like a less
than one I think it's like point four
point three percent of all 50 year
periods actually had one of these 50
year or 35 year multidecadal megatons
very very rare ar1 they become a little
more common and power law we can't quite
ignore them 15% of all 50 year chunks
had one of these 35 year mega droughts
in so this is a purely statistical in a
probabilistic approach to the problem
and it gives you an answer actually
these two are more or less both of them
consistent with the paleoclimate
estimates of 12 two-decade-old routes
per century and 122 multidecadal mega
droughts / millennia there's a
consistency there so then the final
thing that we looked at that we're
interested in using to come back to this
question of how likely our mega droughts
in the future our global climate models
not only are they able to be run for
hundreds of years in standalone mode
with boundary conditions set to
pre-industrial levels which could give
you a nice benchmark in and of itself
they also are of course being used to
assess and plan for climate change
occurring from human activities this
century there the crystal ball into the
future and we don't think we have no
reason to think that the statistics of
the past whether these are inferred from
paler climate archives or statistical
model Monte Carlo methods alone we have
no reason to think that those should be
stationary into the future when we're
changing climate and if we're changing
climate very significantly there's
there's very very little reason to
expect those ratios of one to two per
century for the Decatur out and 12 to
probe eleni inform ult IDK don mega
droughts to hold up into the future so
that's why we need to look at the GCMs
it's a requirement for trying to get it
right for this century I think
everyone's pretty familiar with the idea
of a GCM it's a global climate model
what i will but i will say about them is
that when i was at ncar think in my
second year there
the chief software engineer for one of
the group's I was working with was
suddenly suddenly put in his two weeks
notice and it's gone it's gone it was
recruited by DreamWorks became an
Imagineer so why did DreamWorks want a
software engineer from n car well
DreamWorks is very interested in
computational fluid dynamics because
when Shrek sails off into the ocean they
want the ocean to look realistic and
doing it in a way that looks realistic
means solving the equations of fluid
flow numerically in a plausible way that
our own intuition will tell us looks
good so that's why people like the chief
software engineer and the group I was
born he gets recruited by places like
DreamWorks also i think they pull up a
dump truck of money and told them to get
in i think that was part of why he
disappeared so quickly so it's the same
basic same set of equations that one
uses for video games for Pixar
DreamWorks solve differently of course
in three dimensions on a grid across
multiple layers in the ocean the
atmosphere and does all the exchanges of
heat and energy and mass that are
important for the whole climate system
these are results from just one model
running out into the future sure you've
seen these kinds of diagrams before
where you've got the different rcps
representative concentration pathways
down here in the low end you know
optimistically we avoid the worst you
know effects of climate change we're
down here on the low end if we just burn
baby burn we're going to end up on the
RCP 8.5 actually if you look recently at
the most the most up-to-date estimates
that I could find on what we're actually
doing compared to the rcps people see in
this we're slightly just a little bit
above the worst case scenario envisioned
in 2001 seven so so we're up here
somewhere bottom line is higher the
number of the IRS CP the more warming we
expect because there's more radiative
forcing and this is a very I don't I
don't want to go into a lot of model
bashing and I love climate models
but there are some serious limitations
that do need to be acknowledged
particularly as they pertain to the
problem of mega drop systematic biases
very small ensemble sizes you know we
assume that because they're based in
physics we can get away with smaller and
sample sizes you don't need a thousand
or 10,000 or hundred thousand
realizations of a GCM if it's doing
something dynamically realistic in the
in the flow of the fluid itself but the
in Samba sizes are still very small and
the natural variability is substantial
one of the systematic biases that could
be particularly relevant for mega
droughts is this one they are oftentimes
too wet in a lot of places in the
northern hemisphere and especially in
North America and even globally this is
the total amount of precipitation in the
models occurring just as an average
millimeters per day and this is G PCB so
this is the observations down here at
the bottom most the models are a little
too wet it's a consideration another one
that we published on a couple years ago
years ago now they have a distribution
of variance is related with us selling
about ccs m3 the old version of the end
car model they are systematically too
high frequency they're pushing
interannual variants around it very high
amplitudes and that relates largely to
the tropical Pacific they fluctuate
between an El Nino and La Nina state not
only to quickly but also for
energetically when you compare the
precipitation spectra power spectrum of
precipitation from the models to the
observations it really looks like it's a
big difference you know factor of maybe
five to ten in some cases on the long
time scales
but even with those considerations and a
couple more they'll list in a second
here we went in we dope in head first
and looked at these very cutting edge is
very this is still very cutting-edge new
area of paleo climate simulation
historically paleo climate simulations
were done for say the mid Holocene 6,000
years ago or the last glacial maximum
where you're really just interested in
the mean climate you get from a fixed
set of boundary conditions the last
millennium trying to simulate decato
multidecadal and multicentric
variability over the last millennium
requires a whole different approach
because you actually care about the time
evolution right it's not a fixed you
know ice sheets here and Earth's orbit
looks like this it's a it's a time of
all vain forcing so you've got volcanic
aerosols to worry about the eruptions in
the past solar variability sunspot
cycles related to solar gromp a total
solar output and of course the gradual
changes in the Milankovitch forcing the
shape of the Earth's orbit its tilt in
particular when you put them all
together these are our primary tool so
it's the best we've got and put them all
together force the model and just to
give you a sense there's an animation
for what it looks like this is going to
be smooth sea surface temperatures so
low pass filtered kadel sea-surface
temperature up here at the top is the
total forcing at the top of the
atmosphere and the map is sea surface
temperature after removing all the
high-frequency variability you can start
to see some of these volcanic events
showing up I'm going to I'm going to
fast-forward this a little bit we can
get to the good stuff
this big 1248 12x you think 1258
eruption all right wait for it it's
coming there's one to another and you
can already say this is decayed ly
through ripped out the interannual
variability the frequency is of the
forcing is very abrupt it's like a delta
function it's very abrupt forcing but
you're seeing it propagate out in these
longer timescales you just happen to
have the center here where there's
volcanic activity and one very
significant there's like 20 this scales
like 25 times the Pinatubo 1993 event
the very significant volcanic eruption
just to remind you the power spectrum of
the proxies look more or less like that
looked like this and the slide that I
showed we're going to can't make the
same calculations from the models is all
of them all the last money and
simulations pre-industrial these are
unforced but about a thousand years long
last windham simulations there's that
reference line from the from the proxies
last money in simulations only through
1850s a pre-industrial portion of the
last millennium simulations and then
just the 20th century it doesn't there's
no that's interesting variability right
it's above what you expect from the null
hypothesis there's not a model out there
today that's generating that level of
low-frequency variability so if it's
dynamically driven it's being interned
it's being generated by processes that
are maybe not very well resolved by the
models on the other hand fits the forced
response to the models which is very
plausible considering how much of an
impact explosive volcanism seems have
it's still not showing up in there and
that could be important for
understanding of Mega Drive and then you
got the small ensemble size want to come
back to this say this is you run for
simulations with a model ccsm three run
for simulations you get this
distribution of some variable but truth
looks more like this well
it's a problem you need to be able to
factor that in you can see this in the
terms of mega droughts so you've got
some shift in the mean and then you've
got to realizations of a model and the
first one there's a mega droughts and
the second one there is it the mean is
the same the variance is being drawn
from the same shift it mean the only a
few realization so does that mean the
probability is 50% no it means you
understand the full PDF of plausible
future climates the big problem we need
to think seriously about and this last
one I'm not going to dwell on very much
but it's potentially a factor that we
haven't accounted for which is that code
has been shared between century between
centers and that can have an impact on
the macro scale behavior of the model so
not necessarily truly independent
because they have software components
that can generate emergent processes
that are similar structural similarities
are workaround for all these
considerations we focus on changes
relative to the 20th century that are in
model relative changes try to use monte
carlo methods to fill out the PDF and
ongoing work I'm really finished is
trying to identify clusters of similar
models and look at the risks within
clock clusters so we can come back to
this question how likely you look at the
GCM world how likely are these mega
droughts and put it all together three
different for sinks RCP 2.64 point 5 8.5
making white noise assumptions about the
underlying statistics of precipitation
you get this increase in risk it's
primarily reflective of the Southwest
getting drier coming down here we're
using different noise models to emulate
the statistics of the model of the GCMs
themselves and again there's this
increase because when you saw before use
power law as your you're generating
process your tendency to persist away
from the mean is greater and then the
combined hi forcing with a assumption
about power law distribution in the
power in the frequency spectrum
gives you the highest estimates of risk
this is only applied to precipitation
that's de kado so 10 year so making
events like the the 1950s drought in the
southwest 1930s Dust Bowl look like
there's you know eighty percent ninety
percent of the realizations seeing
events like that and then multidecadal
mega drove so this is really the take
home from precipitation only doesn't
even factor in the temperature effects
you've got thirty five year average
giving you conditions on in the models
that are as dry or drier than the 1930s
we're emulating this with different
noise models but in all cases I would
call this a very non negligible level of
risk thirty forty fifty percent chance
that we're going to be seeing a
background shift waiting the dice
towards making these events which
historically paler climate view of the
world have only occurred one or two
times per millennium but this century
because of this shifted baseline they're
much more probable I'm going to finish
here because I need to go teach a class
and this isn't just the US we're not
alone you look globally do the same
types of calculation the u.s. is just
one pocket of the world that looks
likely to be exposed to this very high
level of risk we turn the crank again
factoring in temperature and it looked
way worse for most of these areas
because in dry areas when it's hot the
demand for moisture goes up and it goes
up with temperature very very
dramatically
you can see that for the Southwest
thousand years in the central plan to
reconstruct a pds I in the future
thousand years of reconstructive PD
assigned in southwest and in the future
and we're really getting away from mega
drug because we're talking about climate
change now we're talking about climate
change at the end of the century in the
you know I would say the the number one
feedback that we got from stakeholders
water resource managers that these
papers were published was that's great
you know I don't but I can't use
information about 2075 I can't deal with
2050 to 2100 being your reference point
what can we do what's actionable now and
so I really shifted my research focus
away from these climate change time
horizons down towards de kadel and
seasonal time horizons because even as
bleak as this picture you'll see this in
the next this animation looks this is
brown is going to be dry this is the
future brown is dry
this is if we just keep on burnin the
rate we're burning or higher that's the
future we have and even as bleak as it
looks it's not it's not actionable
enough we want to be able to see things
unfolding and closer to real time as
they have it so that's where focus on
now we're focusing on seasonal
prediction and de kado prediction and
trying to get knotted this long
timescale not at the low frequency end
but really switching several orders of
magnitude down towards the higher
frequency n to the power spectrum so
I'll end there cuz I gotta go pretty
soon you thank you yes that's de kado
yes probably I mean without climate
change you would have a chance of
probably one or two times per century
now it looks like it's been getting
wetter right so we don't know we haven't
assessed the Northeast yet i used the
story of that drought because my
mother-in-law lived in the 60 it lived
in the New York City during the 60s and
she she remembers the signs in the
subway that said save water shower with
a friend so that's there you go lucky
people of the Internet I said it I'm on
camera saying it yes
yeah we want to branch out globally I
mean I think this is one of these cool
things about being a land-grant
university is that these the methods
apply wherever we want them to
essentially you know they've if you have
great paleo climate records you can do a
better job but even if you don't these
preliminary estimates are probably
actionable in some cases for long time
scales of water resource management so
for building dams are looking at
strategic aquifer reserves that kind of
thing yep I think that's the idea I mean
an hour more short-term more actionable
and scaled out to other places that use
water which is you know everywhere this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu